[Applause]
does governor cuomo have nipple
piercings
he definitely does i mean you can see
them
like he's got that white shirt you saw
the one with the white shirt
now why do you think the media has
flipped on him because
you've noticed this right he's the media
darling
and then all of a sudden when it looks
like he's not going to be president
complete flip i think he wore this
outfit he'd be fine
i think he has this outfit i bet he has
it but he's
wearing it up there in new york yeah i i
actually can't
try too much i'm not trying to shoot my
horn yeah
but i've learned their weird psychology
and so
they had all the democratic governors
send covered patients because it's real
but only kills you if you're deficient
vitamin d and sea and zinc
into nursing homes with old people in
the dark that can die
that's why black folks died double the
number two because black folks eat three
times
the sunlight why people need and that's
a fact so that's why it's like double
number of black stocks they don't tell
you
hey you need sunlight about you need
vitamin d3 so that's a public service
announcement right there not
really not being a virtue signal no
that's a fact you need votes that's true
minorities have less vitamin d in my
entire life every time i got a physical
my vitamin d was always low really and
you have small d
yeah he's a little no no no here's the
wrong deal
we're all evolved this planet it's real
yeah so when you're up north you got to
get more light because there's none
right when you're in the equator it's
dangerous you block it
so black folks need three times what a
northern european needs
like so that's real deal that's
interesting so if i have
a little bit of sun that's going to work
three times better than if alex gets
that same amount of stuff yeah
ah okay that's it and this thing the
melanin blocks it
so this is such a sophisticated virus
why is being in the sun the thing that
stops it from well
because if you stitch together all these
things but the sun it's called
it's called essential like waters
essentially you die in five days without
it yep
uh food's essential down a month without
it what's in food
minerals and vitamins so if you don't
have vitamin d3
you die because any virus your your cell
can't protect yourself
mitochondria gets weak and being
reprogrammed so it's not that not having
sun kills you but the second you get
sick
it's over your bicameral the second
you're hit by a virus mm-hmm
and you don't have d3 don't i'm not i'm
not the virtue segment i care about
everybody
if you're an african-american or african
whoever wherever you're at if you're
from africa yeah particularly you got
dark skin if you
don't have d3 you die we die too yeah
it's just that
we're from northern klein so less sun
works on us
so that's why you have a double amount
of black folks dying yeah
of it because they don't have the sun
okay so you're saying cuomo and the
nursing home patient all right cuomo
nursing
well again the matter they're black or
white they're in a dark room yep
nobody's visiting them yeah they have no
d3 yeah their guts are messed up they
don't absorb it d3 something that knows
we're well with the gut
and so cuomo got an advisory
through the u.n through fauci and that's
why the new jersey governor
the michigan governor the pennsylvania
governor all the democratic governors
said
you are going to basically
take people into your nursing homes that
do this so they looked at cuomo
and they said well okay it's coming out
that we kill all those people in these
nursing homes get covered
sub it's eugenics basically bill gates
talk about let's get rid of old people
let's go ahead and burn cuomo as a
sacrificial lamb and i said this a year
ago
i said you watch leticia james the
attorney general
and she will indict cuomo within a year
i'm on record people are freaking out
about this
because they're going to burn him to
scare all the other governors
that actually signed on see that's
that's the scare of them
so he's the sacrificial lamb who did
what they said it's he's too dumb
to go hey i was told by the un and
fouchy to do this and trump
because he won all the credit because he
won all the credit wow instead of going
i was told to do this they'll drop it as
a potato
but as soon as i said that i talked
people in the governor's office they
went okay
now it's sexual harassment so as soon as
cuomo went i was told to do this they
went oh
sexual harassment so see it's not that
cuomo's a good guy he's a bad guy
but that's what's going on and who's
putting out the sexual harassment
stories why are they timed
well notice they say these women aren't
like he he banged me or whatever yeah
he grabbed me and hugged me at a
christmas party and i'm not defending
him it's like 10 women
yeah once he told me i was good
good-looking yeah so it's like it's not
that it's bad that he killed all these
old people
yeah that's all right you know he's a
dire so many people
yeah earlier yeah he's up so but but but
now his staff that's cancelable is what
you're saying
well it just it's better to say the
governor's been stepping down
because he hugged some girls and told
him they were hot instead of he killed
sixteen thousand old people why the [ __ ]
is that the case why do we care more
about
the ten girls who said they were hugged
they changed the subject 16
000 dead people that's kind of crazy you
know
it shows how they bait and switch the
number one thing i was taught
doing research is the cia the number one
thing i was talking joking folks
way above the cia the way
you kill a story with a story break it
down
so the story is he's killing the old
people we want to kill that story with
these girls
all right let's just say it comes out
alex jones strangled his neighbor
yeah for whatever reason yeah well i
immediately
which is hypothetical i just said frogs
are gay no i just say something like
neighbor was running meth lab jones
discovered it it doesn't matter now it
changes the subject and then i changed
it again
oh and and and he was attacking his wife
and it didn't matter it's true
it just changes the subject and so they
basically change the subject to
something that is potentially forgivable
you know exactly he didn't kill 16 000
old people
no no jones didn't kill his neighbor he
was saving the neighbor's wife
i didn't know if jones killed her but i
heard the neighbor was hurting the wife
i was like oh but the thing that they
change it to
has to be something that the public will
forgive right exactly that's why it's
lesser like exactly
you can't forgive the death i saw him
beating her by the pool what was he
supposed to do
yeah like i mean called kay cuomo told
the girl he loves her
he apologized oh he kissed her at the
christmas things better eat a sausage
you